vor allem als jemand der natürlich eine
gesellschaft haben will die frei von
rassismus ist eine gesellschaft wo alle
menschen egal wo sie herkommen gleich
behandelt werden aber diese anti
rassismus business und geschäft ist von
unserer regierung und von vielen
aktionen in den händen von ganz
radikalen gruppierungen
identitätspolitik
politische gruppierungen entscheiden was
rassistisch und was nicht richtig und
staat rassismus zu bekämpfen das
begleitet uns seit dem geht bei dem die
menschen sind seitdem wir in gruppen
denken wir kategorisieren wir versuchen
die leute abzuwerten wie nicht zu
unserer gruppen gehören aber identitäts
politiker die zum beispiel von alten
weißen männer reden die neue deutsche
medienmacher die dann von goldenen
kartoffel ein negativ an schmähpreis an
diejenigen geben die das kritisieren was
da eigentlich passiert dass wir statt
rassismus zu bekämpfen immer wieder auch
im namen von anti rassismus menschen in
farben in region religionen in herkunft
teilen und stars dass wir das gemeinsame
suchen statt dass wir menschen alles
menschen wahrnehmen tun wir im namen von
anti rassismus das was rassismus
eigentlich ist wünschen nach ihren
höhepunkt und hautfarbe zu teilen
genau ich stimme ihnen vollkommen zu ich
habe ein ganzes buch über die thematik
bestimmen und die lage stimmt ja ich
habe diese gastiert in meinem buch so
bringen sie
nein es ist wirklich einfach eine
ideologie die einmal den besten mit
weißen menschen und die ganze westliche
kultur als täter anteils und alle
muslime und migranten oder homosexuelle
als opfer und an dieser struktur kommt
eben überhaupt nichts mehr merken die
menschen nicht wirklich als
gleichberechtigter war sondern sind nur
opfer und wie gehören zu einer gruppe
vor allem das heißt sie sind nicht
individuen die können unterschiedlich
sein übriges wenn man in afrika schaut
wenn man arabische länder anschaut dann
ist das rassismus auch da das ist nicht
eine erfindung von kolonialmächten dass
es nicht eine erfindung von den alten
weißen mann wo man wieder menschen
aufgrund ihrer alter und
hautfarbe teilt und zwar negativ auch
abwertet das sind phänomene das ist so
eine wichtige thema warum macht unsere
bundesregierung damit warum macht die
bundeszentrale mit warum machen
diejenigen die in der verantwortung mit
und geben diese so wichtige thema solche
radikalen randgruppe
ich weiß es nicht es ist
weiß ich also ich find ich finde die art
und weise wie zum beispiel diskussionen
über den islam ablaufen
da zeigt sich manchmal finde ich der
basis muss also wenn wir jetzt zum
beispiel aktivistinnen nehmen wie hitler
geschah wo es klar ist die kommt aus
ganz problematischen ecken hatte schon
mit islamisten kontakt trotzdem wird sie
immer wieder eingeladen und alles was
sie sagt auch da die qualitäts
politische inhalte forderungen völlig
verboten wird dann auch in talkshows als
bejubelt beklatscht genau das gleiche
wie alice es dass diese junge schwarze
aktive sind ja ein buch geschrieben hat
wieso ich nicht mit weißem über das es
muss im leben kann auch sie wurde sogar
von fdp-politikern beklatscht obwohl in
dem buch wirklich richtig hardcore
schlimme sachen entstehen oft zu machen
würde ich das sogar ihr freund sogar
weiße männer die sich in sie verliebt
station immer noch das ist sein werden
also man geschickt diese koloniale ärzte
überhaupt nicht mehr aus sich heraus und
da denke ich mir wie kann es sein dass
wir da jetzt junge berlin der
fdp-politiker haben die da einfach so
applaudieren und da denke ich mir das
ist eigentlich der warte dass das muss
dass man den leuten nicht auf augenhöhe
begegnet und sagt okay du bist schwarz
aber du siehst es vielleicht trotzdem
blödsinn das wäre eine kommunikation auf
augenhöhe sondern sagt sie nein bis
schwarz du bist dann auch für unterwegs
alles gesagt entschuldigung nun ganz
kurz man hat das alles alternativlos und
zwar kauft man hat gesagt diese gruppe
kann jetzt rassismus in diese
gesellschaft bekämpfen das ist nicht
alternativlos es gibt ansätze wie man
wirklich rassismus bekämpft und das ist
nicht nur indem man menschen in gruppen
teil sondern indem man menschen als
individuum wahrgenommen werden
unabhängig von ihrer herkunft allerdings
für die hautfarbe das ist eigentlich das
anti das wahre antirassismus findet aber
in unserer gesellschaft gar nicht statt
in den medien auch übrigens nicht
das geht ja gesagt wird der gitarrist
thematisiert als color blind was ja also
wenn man wenn man menschen wenn man sagt
man sieht keine hautfarben sondern man
möchte menschen als menschen behandeln
er gibt dass er bestimmte theoretiker
denn die übrigens auch von der
bundeszentrale für politische bildung
empfohlen werden so binde anschluss zum
beispiel die sagt das ist eine weiße
ideologie so was will eben interessant
ist etwas an das stichwort eben dass ich
gerne aufgreifen möchte von der
kolonialen erbsünde sein theologisch
übergriffen entschuldigt der absender
und leider gottes hat diese debatte oft
auf eine ungute weise etwas
theologisches man spricht dann war ich
mal auch vom mercure ibis muss also ich
bin schuld dass das im westen die
haltung ist jemand gegenüber der eigenen
geschichte einzunehmen hat ich bin
schuld der weise mann ist schuld an
allem elend der welt und in deutschland
werden offenbar besonders gerne jene
personen hofiert die gewissermaßen die
peitsche des argumentes und der schuld
einreden es besonders heftig fühlen das
hat irgendwas von einem einem
dominoeffekt sozusagen also je stärker
der westen sich anklagen lässt umso
besser fühlt sich der westen zumindest
in deutschland als dieser mehr kubismus
und dadurch haben wir ein ganz schlimmes
problem es gibt rassismus es gibt
rassismus dann darf man nicht leuten in
der iss stimmen und ist immer falsch
egal wer ihn gegen wen macht es gibt
allerdings auch rassismus als totschlag
keule es gibt auch rassismus als ein
vorwurf den man nur macht um selbst
macht zu bekommen im diskurs und das ist
das schwierige das zu unterscheidenden
echten rassismus vom vorgetäuschten
rassismusvorwurf um an die töpfe der
macht zu bekommen um einfluss zu
bekommen was wäre aus ihrer sicht ein
vorgetäuschter das ist ja ein
vorgetäuschter rassismus wäre zb wenn
ich eben eine eine koloniale
vergangenheit und das beispiel zu nehmen
dass wir im gesamten westlichen hätten
in der gesamten westlichen welt haben
wenn wir das nun primär in deutschland
in deutschen beispielsweise vor wenn wir
beispielsweise die koloniale
vergangenheit von belgien von
großbritannien außen vor das ist ja
nichts was flächendeckend oder was
wirklich passiert momentan hinter button
die wir hier in berlin haben findet es
schon statt dass wir also und sie lösen
müssen vom von burden of the white men
und zu sagen ich muss sagen dass
überlegungen sie sagen der derwesten der
pflege die kultur des mea culpa das ist
doch nicht die mehrheit der bevölkerung
dass das ist doch das sind doch kleine
gruppen die das seien aber die
bevölkerung des eingeschätzt hat weil
man die behörde ist ein gewinner aus die
ist also die mitte ist schweigt die ding
definitiv nicht so also wenn man hängen
gesprächen mit den leuten die leute
finden das eigentlich unerträglich wenn
der alltäglich aber aber dann ist ja
ihre kritik er sozusagen am öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk in dem fall die das
mit finanzieren oder an diesen gruppen
richte entschuldung sie die die
bundesregierung hat eine milliarde euro
ca und der bundesregierung die der auch
sein die aktuell sie da sind nicht nur
die den dieser preis ist eine milliarde
euro für eine bessere gesellschaft und
diese gelder gehen zum großen teil ein
identitäts politischen radikalen
randgruppe rungen die genau dieser
rassismus zementieren auf eine andere
art und weise das ist nicht nur die
medien das ist nicht nur die
offensichtlichen das ist auch in manchen
schulen auch im bereich der
antirassismus fortbildung das sind
zustände die man nicht mehr verschweigen
darf unsere gesellschaft muss in der
lage sein menschen als individuum
wahrzunehmen und nicht als teil von
gruppen und das machen die rassisten
nicht und das machen die antifaschisten
nicht und warum glauben sie dass die
mehrheit eingeschüchtert ist wie sie
gesagt haben von wem ich gebe ihnen ein
beispiel wenn wir jetzt die verbindung
zu ende bringen und sie sagen mir
herrmann sowie waren sehr schlecht wir
haben schlecht deutsch gesprochen ihre
themen haben wir nicht richtig
kommuniziert und ich sage ihnen
entschuldigung sie sind doch was ist sie
sagen das weiß ich auch manchmal so
heißt sie sind sofort auch
eingeschüchtert und darum geht es und
das ist die eingestellt rassismus deren
diese gesellschaft gibt bin ich von
quoten rede ich will hier sitzen ich
will eine funktion haben in mein leben
ich will karriere machen aufgrund von
meine leistung nicht aufgrund von meinen
namen oder meine religion wie und das
ist wie häufig haben sie in ihrem leben
rassismus erlebten rassismus
also am anfang weil ich auch nicht die
sprache beherrschte sehr oft aber ich
habe ganz schnell bemerkt rassismus kann
man bekämpfen indem man welt sicher auch
den gegen ober zeigt das lasse ich mit
mir nicht machen und das versuche ich
auch die jugendlicher mit denen ich
arbeite auch zu vermitteln natürlich
mussten wir auch gesellschaftlicher
ebene viele ändern aber ich bin nicht
der meinung dass deutschland ein
rassistische land alles zum beispiel
saudi arabien oder syrien oder die
palästinensischen gebieten in denen ich
zum beispiel sehr oft war wenn sie sagen
dass es jetzt darum geht beim anti
rassismus kampf darum geht dass man
gruppen betrachtet und nicht das
individuum wie sie gesagt haben das ist
als weiße ideologie dargestellt wird
wenn wir nicht das individuum betrachten
sondern in gruppen wer hatte wer hat
daran interesse kann das eine erklären
er einen staunend davor dass das so ist
also ich glaube es geht es geht
letztendlich um eine ideologie also das
haben ja ideologien so an sich dass sie
eben die welt in der totale einteilen
und sich sehr richtig anfühlen aber ist
das auch um macht aus übungen geht das
kuscheltier phänomen liefere diese diese
diese minderheiten werden nicht als
gleichberechtigte bürger wahrgenommen
sondern als
alles gruppen die man schützen sollen
aber man nimmt sie nicht ernst man nimmt
wie nicht als gleichberechtigter teil
und das es wert von politischen islam
aber auch von radikalen linken natürlich
will bevor wir